افغانستان تنتقل من ازمه الى اخرى والقاسم
المشترك بين هذه الازمات هو قياده طالبان
وما يسري بينها من خلافات لا تظهر جلي
للعيان
ولكن نتائجها وتاثيرها ينعكس على شعب
افغانستان الفقير الجائع
اولى علامات الشرخ هي البعد الجغرافي بين
قياده الحركه في معقلها الاصلي قندهر
والقياده السياسيه والاداريه في العاصمه
كابول فالقائد الاعلى الملا هبه الله
اخوان زاده ومستشاروه قابعون في جبال
قندهار بعيدا عن عاصمه البلاد وبالتالي هم
بعيدون عن صوت الشعب الافغاني الذين
يديرون شؤونه عبر الفتاوى كتلك التي منع
التعليم الفتيات وعمل النساء في المؤسسات
الانسانيه الدوليه
الوزراء التابعون للحركه والذين يمارسون
ما لديهم من سلطات قليله في كابول بداوا
يعبرون عن امتعاضهم ولو بشكل مبطن حيث
القى وزير الداخليه سراج الدين حقاني
خطابا قال فيه انه على طالبان تهدئه
المواطنين والتصرف بطريقه لا يكرهها الناس
ويكرهون معها الدين في اشاره الى القرارات
المتزمته التي فاقمت الفقر والجهل في
البلاد كما ان حقاني انتقد احتكار السلطه
الذي يضر بسمعه النظام باكمله مشيرا ولو
ضمنيا الى قله صلاحيات وعجز الوزراء في
كابول مقابل وجود كل خيوط السلطه بيد
اخونتزاده ومساعديه مؤشرات قال مراقبون
انها تدل على انشقاقات وشيكه في حركه
طالبان التي تدفع سياساتها المته وره
البلاد الى المجاعه انس نماسي العربيه